the vaccine news comes at a desperate
time the u.s has added around
a million new cases of the virus in less
than a week
that brings the national total above 11
million
as daily cases rise in 49 states
across the country and with so many
cases in such a short time many
hospitals are on the brink of getting
overwhelmed carter evans is in hard hit
salt lake city
where icu's are almost full carter good
morning to you how much more
can hospitals take there well not much
more at
all and that's the problem and that's
why doctors and nurses
are now pleading with people to help
them get this virus under control
we spoke with one doctor who says he has
patients who are in the hospital
who have tested positive for the virus
but still don't believe this pandemic is
real
he says he's seen more human suffering
in the last month than he has in his
entire career
covid cases are pushing utah's hospitals
to the brink and things are almost
certainly going to get worse according
to dr brandon webb
it's almost like watching this a
slow-motion train wreck you know what's
coming
and it looks horrible that's the problem
with the mathematics of this
is that we do know what's coming we're
seeing so many cases
day over day that unless definitive
steps are taken to interrupt the
transmission cycle
exceeding capacity is a mathematical
inevitability
many front line workers are already
stretched thin by work that's physically
exhausting and emotionally draining
like nurse katrina emery families are
always looking for hope but sometimes
there's just not a lot of hope to give
them
grim scenes continue to unfold in el
paso texas
where county inmates were loading bodies
into mobile morgue trucks over the
weekend
the county judge there says using inmate
labor indicates the city's level of
staff shortages
more than 200 people have died in that
city from covet
in the last month with cases and
hospitalization smashing records at
least 27
states have imposed new coronavirus
restrictions on businesses
and gatherings in the last two weeks on
sunday in michigan which saw
at least 496 deaths from kovitt last
week
the governor announced a three-week
freeze on indoor dining
and in-person learning for high school
and college students
if we don't take aggressive action right
now
we could soon see 1 000
deaths per week here in michigan but
without more targeted restrictions
hospital systems nationwide could be
just weeks away from their breaking
point
according to infectious disease expert
michael osterhome
my worst fear is what we saw happen in
in other countries
where people were dying on the streets
people literally were dying in the
waiting room of emergency rooms after
spending 10 hours
just waiting to be seen that's going to
start happening
and we will see the breadth and the
depth of this tragedy
and then of course there is the economic
fallout from the pandemic which is still
a huge issue take a look at the line for
this food bank this is near dallas
a line of cars spilling out onto the
freeway as food for some
25 000 people was distributed over the
weekend
organizers say that is their largest
food giveaway
ever anthony stunning pictures there
carter thank you very much